for those of you that for those of you
who don't know me I'm Karen Lightman I
am now the executive director of Metro
21 smart cities Institute I've been here
for a little more than four months it's
been a tremendous I do need the back
monitors on again they were just on so
I'm really honored and it's been a great
honor worse Rick was sitting there but
now he's gone okay where's Rick there's
right there he is you're just hanging
out you're that's I know
so I'm Rick Stafford and ROG they've
been my mentors and guide through this
journey I've come a long way and it's
been an honor and a delight actually to
work with Carnegie Mellon and today has
been I think a great celebration of the
fantastic work being done here that's
been done here for 100 over 100 years at
Carnegie Mellon and then with smart
cities here with Metro 21 since 2014 so
I am I came here from running MEMS and
sensors industry group micro
electromechanical systems they were
talking about sensors and actuators
those are MEMS okay so they forgot to
say that I was going to interrupt but I
decided I'd wait till later and so yeah
all the stuff Bosh does would not exist
if not for MEMS you forgot to include
that as well and you're talking but
that's ok yeah that's true
and actually if you come to my office
you'll see a picture that was made for
me by the folks at MEMS and bashed men
it's in any case part of what I did when
I ran conferences for MEMS industry
group and MEMS and sensors was I would
do kind of trip notes for people I would
do the summary of the day it would
capture funny quotes and sometimes we
would do it as a competition I'm working
my way into that so eventually you guys
can do be it could be collaborative you
could be a part of this process but I
decided I put together a couple of
slides to talk about what were the key
thoughts and now the issue is I cannot
read very well so what I did is and will
have all of this for download free
so if you want to you know keep that for
you but I went through everybody and I
want to thank my work studies Bob Santa
Maria and Jason Grace who helped me pull
together the key thoughts of the
speakers that we had today
leading off with Farnum and I what I
thought was fantastic it was his message
that Metro 21 is now an Institute fully
supported by Carnegie Mellon and it's
talking about Carnegie Mellon's
expertise in connecting technology and
humanity he also talked about how we're
at a critical inflection point and we
have an opportunity and this is really
critical there's so much noise about
smart cities there's so much noise and
everyone's trying to make a buck in
smart cities and I feel like Carnegie
Mellon can play a role as a neutral
forum for kind of getting through all
the muck and the noise and bringing some
sense of we could be neutral we can
bring some fresh at this issue of a
science of smart cities so I think that
was what was fantastic about what Farnum
shared and so and now is the time to act
as sort of his last thing rich
Fitzgerald he's such a great booster of
Carnegie Mellon so we're and I love his
stories about how far we've come as a
region and so what he was talking about
is how I'm out now to Metro 21 is
launching a new idea Pittsburgh can be a
premier city by levering leverage
leveraging its research and municipal
resources and that speaks to the MOU
that we have not only with the city but
also with Allegheny County and speaking
of the city we had Karina Rick's here on
behalf of mayor Peduto and she talked a
lot about researching new technologies
it which is important for partnership
between CMU is critical to the work they
do that the city can benefit from
research coming from everything from
Carnegie Mellon has to offer from
material science to public policy we
have emails with the city of Pittsburgh
folks almost daily leave but you know we
are in touch with each other trying like
when there's flooding you know we're
coming up with solutions
coming to up coming up coming to us with
their problems I think that speaks
highly of the work that we do with our
partners and currently now with the city
and the county and that we are let's say
I'll just click through this but can
look they'll continue to transform that
sort of grant Oliphant there was just
too much that he said I could have I
mean I wanted to steal his talking notes
because everything he talked about was
so perfect and David Danks was also
really excited because he talks a lot
about AI and society and a lot of what
Grant was talking about that so we tried
to capture some of that here that as a
technology is not ethics neutral it can
magnify inequality and the costs are
high I think that was something that you
also heard from Alexandre when she spoke
we need to optimize the right things
with ethics baked-in we have resources
to build a world that works for everyone
but when it's missing this issue of
abundance inequity so we can we have an
opportunity and we need to make sure
that we the foundation of what we do for
smart cities is done and baked in at the
rate at the at the beginning the last
part is sort of echoing that as well is
we need to build back trust in science
and technology and we can pull off this
challenge and I thought the last part
that was important is that behind the
end endowments is willing to fund it
that was good news too so well continue
the good work and it looks like there
they'll continue to be a partner of ours
Raj again lots of points here too many
on the slide in fact and that I that the
system of systems is much like a
fine-tuned Swiss watch that becomes a
Smart Watch with lots of applications
you talked about trust we talked about
that throughout the day in fact trust
security privacy all those issues are
really critical metro 21 is a change
agent we need to work with our partners
and we talked a lot about this panel was
a perfect way of talking about that and
this issue of building a science of
smart cities with consideration for
policy in people is really important and
we're looking to leverage the the
innovations of Technology and their
interplay and like I say is we want to
do this for good you know we're using
technology for good everyone is starting
at a good place so we need to make sure
that we understand the implications um
yeah so I'm realizing now this font was
way too small workmates apologize I'm
trying to read the back I'm used to
having like I should actually pull up my
life
hey I do you know what maybe I'll even
pull up my laptop just read yeah it just
read you don't mind if I do
I guess I'm I can't cuz I'll have to
stand there um and you can be too you
can read with me so but I think this was
this was art this was caught we called
the deans panel but what this was the
deans and then Don Carter right there we
had and and yeah but I think this idea
they really came back to it's all about
people I wanted to put this in bold and
that you need to be it needs to be
personalized in participating and it
needs to be focused on the use cases we
talked about workforce that that was
fantastic I got we've got two kids in
the public school system so I'm really
impressed with the work that we're doing
here at Carnegie Mellon we need a high
quality education that keeps individuals
to adapt to the rapid changes and
technologies and good education is local
and Carnegie Mellon has been doing some
great work in partnering and I love the
fact that that's gonna that is part and
will continue to be a part of what we do
at Metro 21 we heard this again and
again this idea that we need to try them
for it that it's not just the university
sitting in its ivory tower but we need
all the folks who were in this room
during this with us use cases again the
fact that we're in a disciplinary is our
secret sauce that policy and people part
is really it's not just tacking I think
was it Andrew Moore who did the MIT
thing I mean that's what stands us apart
a lot from these high tech universities
is because we really are focused on the
policy and the people we talked about
ownership of data and then we asked them
you know how what should Metro 21 do in
the future and I thought it was
important that they said and and we hear
this too is it's communities are not
just cities I mean of course
80% of the world's population is going
to be in cities by 2020 but it's also
the exurbs and the suburbs around it and
we're gonna be doing more work and not
just the metropolitan areas but those
areas as well
and then lastly infrastructure obviously
as you make your way here and lose two
tires to a pothole you realize that
infrastructure is a really big deal as
well so Dave Roger was great I love that
I've told this story I've only been here
for four months but I'm telling this
story about Henry Hillman sitting at a
stoplight looking at Carnegie Mellon and
realizing we've got we've got to be able
to do a better job here and he you know
gave us money so what we could have what
we have now and then they saw traffic 21
we owe a lot to the great work of Chris
Hendrickson and Stan Caldwell and Raj as
well for the great work they've done
with traffic 21 we we are now standing
on their shoulders and metro 21 will
continue that work and that I also
thought it was good about how David
talked about the different groups have
different ways of looking at problems
and that's something that they want to
make sure that we and that's that
interdisciplinary thing as well so this
is a full slide the the science of smart
cities panel what a great group of folks
I thought it was great it's not just you
know it's that what's the science of
smart cities its data science and
collaboration don't look at a particular
point of a city or a series of
individuals in the city seek to extent
understand the city globally across
space and time edge computing is much
like you were talking about the human
body with or a nervous system the
sensing and processing causality I think
that was something that Manuelo was
talking a lot about this inner inner
connectivity that we need to be thinking
about as well as cities are highly
constrained at predictable systems and
you know her her joke about how she
loves The Truman Show I hate the Truman
Show
I love life's unpredictability but I
also want to get to work on time right
so I think it's that balance of the of
that is something that we should be
thinking about in Metro 21 we also
talked a little bit little door
about responsibility and culpability and
we should be thinking about how these
things need to be open and transparent
and I know that's something very core to
the work that we do here in Carnegie
Mellon and I know we'll continue lastly
I was trying to get as much as I could
out of this last panel but I was typing
and I knew I was gonna present so I hope
I caught everything but we we wanted to
talk about how the city of Pittsburgh
evaluates opportunities from the
business end and the Port Authority
needs to do what it does to be the most
attractive place for transportation and
I know you've got a large job ahead of
you Katherine but we know you can do it
seven weeks in is that what you said
yeah okay you're doing great data
infrastructure cloud computing and
application development are the three
pillars the partnerships are a way to
move projects forward but the funding
models need to be adaptive to the city
exploring these solutions that's very
true there are many challenges with open
and iterative data infrastructure
analytics and there's this issue of
wireless broadband and fiber that's
something I know we're really struggling
but here in Pittsburgh that not
struggling but we know it's a challenge
and we are we are meeting it we are we
are going to meet it and we want to take
Pittsburgh to the the next level of
smart cities that infrastructure is
really core to that and then this issue
of standards where I came from and the
semiconductor and mem space I called it
my three legged stool which was
standards interoperability and power so
they all remain very important here too
but it was great to hear you guys talk
about standards and interoperability
because we can't if we just keep having
one offs and one offs and one offs we're
not gonna get anywhere um so then I
started doing like kind of favorite
quotes that summer you know that most of
them are clean I think and so Grant had
a few make sure that we're at the
epicenter of making technology work for
the many not for just the few the IEEE
Raj this is so perfect for you is the
greatest idea in the world when I'll
take root if it's not funded by someone
that's my favorite and then Laurie Metro
21 is taking this Institute say smart
cities out of the lab and into the
streets and then Jim I don't know if
you're still here yeah but maybe you
don't want your name attached this but I
love the idea of having you do that
minority report for infrastructure so
that the data the the potholes can be
predicted before they happen to produce
good learning outcomes we need to
incorporate local knowledge and feedback
that's Richard China's and Krishna and
Jim showed me what metro 21 was doing to
address society's greatest challenges
and remorse oh that's a great question
and I think equity this issue of equity
as well krishnan talked about as well
and then Don your quote is both you and
Shakespeare what is the city but the
people and then I figured it would be
good segue to Denmark that Alex was
talking about you know when Denmark is
coming to you to learn about using data
to improve your welfare system child
welfare system you're doing it right and
then her other point was you need to
learn from the problems not the not
perpetuate them man you Ella had many
quotes but she was talking about how
it's a kind of the interdisciplinary
component of the machinery of smart
cities and then jose whatever we were
doing with data and analysis machine
learning or AI needs to improve the
lives of citizens we can't build black
boxes we have more smart cities are
interesting because they put computer
science ideas into practice Kristen we
work in silos but we need to cross
educate so we understand and then Lee we
have to be cautious about the
investments we make in the city to get
the maximum benefit from tax dollars for
our citizens at that that was a good
city of Pittsburgh quote for you and
then Jim young connective tissue to
power in the infrastructure the stuff
that you don't see is what you do a
crown castle and then again something
that you take you don't come you don't
tell people how great your bus ride was
right you tip and that's what you want
you don't want anyone talking about
their bus rides because it shows that
you're doing you know your job well and
and the Port Authority and the buses are
going on time and that's gonna be a part
of a smart cities about that these
things should be
Actimel and reliable and no one thinks
about them and then this is really
important Richard where are you sitting
is he still here Richard we as a
regulatory the regulatory component is
so important and I think that's I'm
really glad that this panel brought it
up and then Frank you got the last word
which was our goal is to improve the
quality of life for citizens and
communities in which we work so
extremely noble work so I pulled out
Raja's summary slide from when he
started because I think it echoes and it
still continues here as an important
point of what we aim to do at Metro 21
and and I won't read that to you because
you've heard it before but this is core
this is our future this is what we're
going forward and we be basically we
want you to come with us on this journey
and we're looking forward to partnering
with many of you if not all of you on
our next step and then lastly just
through the slide in here I've been
getting a lot of thank-yous and
congratulations from everybody but I am
really grateful to the hard work of the
folks who are many of not in this room
because they're doing the work for the
next stage but I want to thank my work
studies Bob and Jason obviously I want
to thank Raj and Rick Stafford and Stan
are you still in the back or he's
heading he's oh you are good okay so
Stan Caldwell as well extremely grateful
and then we also have the team from CMU
marketing and we've got some other folks
like Natasha and Chelsea and Steve and
Katie so thank you for making this a
great event and thank you for all of you
for your participation and I think the
last two people I want to thank our gym
and Krishnan because we came to you with
this idea for today and you said go for
it and look what we did so thank you and
I do have some closing closing thoughts
Saddam so I guess I just what I guess
talk a little bit about next steps if
you are just to highlight what Karen
just said unique aspects of what we are
trying to do interdisciplinary in nature
right and then deployments in the real
world to solve real world problems right
and then meanwhile we want to take a
scientific approach which enables
fundamentally new ways of thinking about
things fundamentally new ways of solving
problems and then as Jim pointed out
there are engineering ways of doing it
as well by trial and error so basically
and then from engineering comes science
from science urine engineering
experiments and so on
so they turn out to be very
complementary so with that as that's the
context what what do we plan to do next
I guess we have a bunch of industry
representatives our out here and then a
public entity represents out here we
would like to basically engage you very
actively very proactively we see kind of
two models of cooperation going forward
the first could possibly be a three-way
relationship between a company Metro 21
and public entity where we basically do
a three-way effort of some kind taking
some products component systems that the
company has to provide adding some
creativity some innovation from the CMU
side and combining the two and then
working with a public entity to actually
deploy that solution in the real world
get some so that's one model a second
model would be where the company works
with basically with CMU with metro to
new one directly right we basically come
up with some good ideas explore some new
frontiers right and then meanwhile odda
Institute metro 21 Institute will
continue to work with the city various
municipalities the County and Beyond
working with the Metro Lab network and
so on so very basically I guess there
are a two two-way relationship going on
right so what we expect to put in place
now that we are ectly a formal Institute
around that the deans have blasted the
interim president les to the pros
was here earlier and the multiple Dean's
actually provided very insightful
comments what we expect to see happen is
that in the near future people we expect
to put in place a framework a structure
a structured way of companies to work
with us
basically we expect to define different
tiers of view with annual dues and such
and each directly getting different
kinds of benefits and then there could I
guess at the higher tiers if we well
there will be options where you'd be
able to define a custom project that you
are interested in so that actually we
could work with the exclusively on you
would act you would have access to some
of the greatest minds on campus some of
which were and display earlier this
afternoon on the faculty panel and then
access to some of these students right
so I guess that was mentioned earlier
one of the biggest assets on campus are
really the students that we have
so basically otherwise that but we'll
put this framework very formally in
front of you let me just finally add
that as a founding member of this
partnership framework you will have more
privileges if you are more benefits than
those who come later right so keep that
in mind so so meanwhile so like I guess
let me just thank a few people on my
friend I guess first of all I guess Jim
and Krishna and I guess a thanks to you
for all the a pioneering vision that has
lasted several years Rick Stafford my
partner in crime and then without lots
of things would not have happened I
guess then meanwhile Karen you saw the
the energy the passion coming forth
right great person to basically launch
this industry partnership if you all
keep in touch I'm available as are the
deans and Karen Rick stand Christine
tricks on out here right so multiple
points of contact here contact anybody
everybody you work you're a comfortable
word and let's basically change cities
for the better right so again thank you
for coming and I actually have I guess
before we go on I guess we are going to
introduce the next post so push the
session are we correct I'm looking at
you yeah yes so I guess so I guess so so
Ricky
perhaps I guess I'd say that so so I
guess it is Friday afternoon we
understand that we appreciate that so we
will actually have beer and chips and
pretzels and then the like if you want
more sugar there will be more sugar
Pizza nacho cheese so I guess we likely
have a poster session showcasing some of
the projects that are ongoing students
talking bragging about what they have
accomplished probe them needle them and
meanwhile have some munchies and then
have a good rest of the weekend okay
[Applause]